Here’s an SCP that’ll give you a serious
case of the Mondays: SCP-3166, a disgusting
monster also known as Gorefield.
It looks like a giant, ratty fursuit of the
character Garfield, from the popular Jim Davis
comic strip of the same name, but the suit
is made out of real cat fur, and its insides
are made from putrid, human-flesh lasagna
that is somehow a genetic match for Jim Davis
himself.
Whenever the Garfield franchise isn’t doing
well, financially or in its public image,
this monster manifests and begins stalking
someone associated with the brand.
If it catches them before the SCP Foundation
can intercept, it’ll either beat them to
death or force-feed them the lasagna from
its own body until they die.
The only way to distract the beast is to leave
some fresh lasagna of your own laying around,
which the beast will immediately take as bait.